twitch is suing two of its users in
connection with hate raids that have
been taking place across the platform
and while this federal lawsuit may go a
long way towards dissuading the two
anonymous defendants
it's probably the threat of future
lawsuits that will be a big step towards
cleaning up the racism and harassment
that have been plaguing twitch recently
so let's dive in and take a look at how
this lawsuit might or might not change
the game
[Music]
before we get started i promise to keep
this short like our new the score
esports youtube shorts channel if you've
ever wanted to see your favorite
streamer try really desperately to
identify animals or esports players
ducking shots that are in a video game
we've got you covered and we can pack a
lot into a minute so go check it out
subscribe to the channel and let us know
what you think about what we've got so
far see you there okay so let's start at
the beginning what exactly is a hate
raid over the course of the last couple
months there's been an increasing number
of bot driven harassment incidents on
twitch essentially what happens is that
a massive number of bots show up and
start spamming harassment in the chat
usually of a bigoted variety
oh y'all are real
time out
this does a few things it makes it
basically impossible for the streamer
and chat to interact it's generally
incredibly disruptive and in some cases
streamers have just called it quits and
ended their stream instead of continuing
moderation tools can sometimes help if
there's obvious slurs in the message but
we're not talking about banning one
person there can be dozens of these bots
in a single chat at any one time and
obviously slurs aren't the only way to
be offensive or to harass people and
there are ways to get around automated
chat filters and still get a shitty
message across while there's always been
people on twitch or really any anonymous
platform who are willing to get banned
to shock or disgust people these hate
raids really started to pick up steam in
august some creators tried to share tips
on how to minimize their effects using
auto moderation tools but when there's
dozens of these bots constantly in your
chat these sorts of tools can only do so
much sub only chat mode can work but
it's definitely not ideal especially if
you're a smaller creator that's trying
to attract subscribers in viewership on
august 11th twitch acknowledged the
existence of the issue in a tweet that
said quote we've seen a lot of
conversation about botting hate raids
and other forms of harassment targeting
marginalized creators you're asking us
to do better and we know we need to do
more to address these issues that
includes an open and ongoing dialogue
about creator safety the tweets go on to
talk about how they're planning to
improve channel level ban evasion
detection as well as account
verification
in order to make these problems less of
an issue but for the month of august
twitch really didn't do much but
streamers did organizing a one-day
walkout called a day off twitch to
protest twitches in action and call
attention to the issues that streamers
have been facing from these raids the
walkout itself was controversial as some
bigger streamers question exactly what
it would accomplish without buy-in from
some of the platform's bigger names it's
slacktivism
okay it's slacktivism like you're gonna
take one day off oh wow jeff bezos is
gonna [ __ ] be quaking in his boots oh
my god he's gonna be afraid he's gonna
be terrified that you take one day off
meanwhile nobody [ __ ] watches you
right so it doesn't even matter because
you don't affect the audience that the
the website has are you joining it yeah
i'll join it i want the i want the
problems to be solved before the strike
even happens i want their that's why i
wanted their demands to be made clear so
that uh a twitch could at least like
respond and then
we could see if they're happy with
those demands the organizers also said
that those who relied on streaming
income and couldn't afford to take a day
off needn't worry about that and while
it's not exactly clear how effective it
was
some estimates put the reduction in
views at about 10 to 15 percent for that
day a couple days later twitch made a
statement about the hate raids via email
and announced a workshop for streamers
to learn how to best use the tools that
exist on twitch already to prevent them
that brings us to the lawsuit which is
dated september 9th the lawsuit alleges
that two twitch users cruise control
from the netherlands and creatine
overdose from austria are linked to
these hate rates by the way creatine
overdose from
austria that sounds like it might be
i'm ballsy i don't take no [ __ ] from
anyone okay of course it's not him of
course it's not arnold it specifically
accuses cruz control of creating over 3
000 bought accounts used for hate raids
and it also points out that creatine
overdose demonstrated the use of botting
software the second name might sound
familiar if you've been following the
situation closely as twitch streamer
sista karen posted a video of the moment
that her channel was hate rated by bots
right before that happens there's a
follow and an offensive message from a
user named creatine overdose creatine
overdose um thank you for following
welcome welcome
how are you
i think that's davis giving this person
a whoop-de-wap go walk you up
oh here we go see
how look at we got followed by it guys
it's so cool give me one second
[Music]
all right
so yep so we got this we're email only
guys so
yeah so just give me a second we're
gonna turn i think we got alerts off
in terms of the actual claims made in
the lawsuit twitch alleges that cruise
control and creatine overdose did three
main things firstly they allege that
they breached their contract with twitch
by breaking the terms of service the
alleged behavior includes racist
homophobic and offensive chat harassment
and defamation creating fake accounts
after being banned manipulating
identifying information interfering with
the enjoyment of other users and
accessing twitch with prohibited bots
the second claim alleges that both users
committed fraud by agreeing to the terms
of service on twitch when they both knew
full well that they had no intention of
ever abiding by those terms this is a
specific kind of fraud known as fraud in
the inducement in the lawsuit twitch
argues that without this
misrepresentation
twitch would never have allowed the
users to make accounts at all and after
banning them they allege the two
defendants agreed to the terms again
when they made even more accounts
sometimes hiding their identities in
locations while doing so the last claim
made is that the defendants are in
violation of a specific california
statute that governs unfair competition
the complaint alleges that cruise
control and creatine overdose quote
engaged in unlawful unfair or fraudulent
business practices or acts as described
above including but not limited to
fraudulent inducement harassing twitch
streamers deploying hostile raids on
twitch and disrupting twitch's services
in the case of each of these claims
twitch notes that it suffered damages
and in addition to whatever financial
compensation is appropriate they're
seeking a court order to prevent both
defendants from ever using twitch
or from assisting other people or
companies who are using twitch ok so
that's probably enough about the lawsuit
itself you may have noticed that we're
not using real names when talking about
these users and twitch's complaint
states that if those are discovered the
complaint will be amended appropriately
so how do things go from this point well
as the washington post's nathan grayson
pointed out in his article twitch has
used lawsuits in the past to subpoena
anonymous users remember back in 2019
when people were streaming anime and
porn in the extremely dead artifact
category on twitch i think i watched
like six episodes of the saga of tanya
the evil on my second monitor when i was
supposed to be writing a script
and that's anime by the way not you know
the other thing wait don't don't tell
keith that cut this part out do you
promise
okay okay cool let's keep going anyways
twitch sued those anonymous users too
referring to them as john and jane does
one through 100 in their lawsuit but
even if they discover the identities of
these two anonymous users through this
lawsuit can suing two people really stop
these hate raids well it could make it a
little bit more difficult for people to
justify even attempting getting sued by
a subsidiary of amazon is probably not
something that factored into the mental
calculus of most of these harassers but
it's also possible that not all of these
people are rational actors i mean
they're spending their free time spewing
hate and harassment on twitch so it's
kind of hard to know to twitch's credit
their spokesperson told the washington
post that the lawsuit is just a single
step in addressing this issue quote this
complaint is by no means the only action
we've taken to address targeted attacks
nor will it be the last and they go on
to continue quote hate and harassment
have no place on twitch and we know we
have a lot more to do but we hope that
these combined actions will help reduce
the immediate and unacceptable harm that
targeted attacks have been inflicting on
our community it's a strange time that
we live in for the dozens of cases where
law enforcement seems so poorly equipped
to handle situations like internet death
threats or swatting we have a subsidiary
of one of the world's biggest
corporations suing two people who they
allege tried to use bots to be as racist
as possible as often as possible on
their platform i think this lawsuit
could do a lot to dissuade people who
convinced themselves that these hate
raids were just jokes even though that's
a really shitty excuse and honestly not
acceptable but twitch also has a lot to
do to make the platform safer for
everyone it seems like twitch is talking
the talk but if they don't follow
through on the changes that their users
need
i think there are a lot of streamers
ready to hold them accountable again
somebody in the okay somebody in the
comments this is gonna end up in the end
board
so i
you know what i don't care somebody in
the comments
the last one of these i did they said
put this at 1.5 speed
you'll thank me later for some [ __ ]
and it's just like
i don't know maybe i do speak slowly
this week i'm like i'm gonna
i'm gonna speak as quickly as possible
and we'll see how you like that maybe
you ought to slow it down put it on 0.5
speed it's too fast
[Laughter]
60 of the time it works every time